はじめ: こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーと
エイジ: エイジです
はじめ: というわけで今ですねぇ
はじめ: エイちゃんの家に居るんですけどもぉ
はじめ: 居るのは僕とエイちゃんの2人だけ
はじめ: んで、りっくん
はじめ: あの、柿ピーみたいな顔の奴
エイジ: （笑い声）
はじめ: リクヲがさっきまで居たんですけどもぉ
はじめ: ちょっと今買い出しに無理やり行かせて
はじめ: 今外にいます
はじめ: やりましょうかと
エイジ: やりましょう。
はじめ・エイジ: やりましょう
はじめ: ついにこのドッキリをする時がきました
はじめ: 用意する物は至ってシンプルです
はじめ: まずは、こちらのナイフ
はじめ: おもちゃなんだよね
はじめ: こう、刺しても痛くなくて
はじめ: こう、ヒュッ、って
はじめ: 収納されるやつです
はじめ: 刺しても収納されるので痛くないという、こうね
エイジ: （笑い声）
はじめ: こっちから見ると刺してる様に見える
エイジ: いや、そんな説明してますけど皆知ってますよ笑
はじめ: あ、そっか笑
はじめ: いやまぁ今回は何をしようかと言いますと
はじめ: このナイフで
はじめ: エイジが間違って
はじめ: 何かの手違いで僕を刺しちゃった時に
はじめ: リクヲはどんな反応をするかと言う
はじめ: まあ、ドッキリですね
はじめ: シンプルなドッキリに見えるんですけどもぉ
はじめ: ちょっと一ひねり入れてやって行きましょう
はじめ: 用意するのはこちらの水風船そして赤の絵の具
はじめ: 作戦としては・・・
はじめ: エイちゃんが俺を刺すんだもんね？
はじめ: 刺すからぁ…
はじめ: 赤の絵の具を使って上手いこと
はじめ: 赤い血を作って
はじめ: その血を水風船に入れて
はじめ: 服の中に水風船を持ってるから
はじめ: そこ目掛けて刺す
はじめ: そしたら赤い血が…
はじめ: ダラダラダラァァ
はじめ・エイジ: （笑い声）
はじめ: コレだけだとさすがに騙せない
はじめ: コレだと普通にたぶんバレちゃうんですけどぉ
はじめ: 実際にその、血が出ると
はじめ: 動揺すると思うんですよ
エイジ: 確かに
はじめ: さすがにね
はじめ: では行こう！
《インターホンの音》
はじめ: りっくん？
リクヲ: ハァイ
はじめ: ごめんちょっとあのー
はじめ: あれも買ってきてもらっていい？
リクヲ: うん？
はじめ: アメリカンホットドック」
はじめ・エイジ: （笑いをこらえる声）
はじめ: まず血を作って行こうと思います
はじめ: 水風船にまず赤い絵の具を入れていきます
はじめ: あ、ほら入ってった
《物が落ちる音》
はじめ: アアア！
はじめ: この水風船の中に水を入れていきます
はじめ: こういう感じでしょ？
はじめ: これでフタをします
はじめ: がんばってフタをします
はじめ: どうどう？できたできた
エイジ: おお、風船2個できてますねぇ
はじめ: 新たな生命がね、ここに誕生しました
はじめ: 血が噴き出る球が完成しました
はじめ: はい、というわけでもう、りっくんが帰ってきます
はじめ: 一応最後に確認をしておこう
エイジ: ハイ
はじめ: コレを俺が持ってても怪しいから
はじめ: エイちゃんが持ってて、こういう感じ
はじめ: 俺に向かってね？
《インターホンの音》
はじめ: こう刺して
はじめ: ベシャァ！って血が出るから
《インターホンの音》
エイジ: なるほど、わかりました
はじめ: 胸かな?腹にしょう
はじめ: 腹で刺してもらいます
はじめ: で、終わった後エイちゃんは…
はじめ: ビックリしてぇ逃走してって
エイジ: 叫びながら外行く
《インターホンの音》
はじめ: というわけで、もう来るのでやっていきましょう
エイジ: もう来るって、もう来てますよ笑
リクヲ: なんで、何回も呼び出したのに出ないの…
エイジ: え～聞こえなかったよ？
リクヲ: めっちゃ呼び出したよ？
リクヲ: 5回くらい鳴らしたよ
はじめ: ありがとうね、りっくん
エイジ: しゃちょー、大食い系成功したことありましたっけ?
はじめ: うん
エイジ: え、な、なんのですか?
はじめ: ミニトマト100個
はじめ・エイジ・リクヲ: （笑い声）
はじめ: え、待って、上がってきたよ
はじめ: うわぁ!エイジ見て？
はじめ: あれ？ｋｇｃじぇｊｋ
はじめ: エイちゃん見て！ファインプレー！
はじめ: エイちゃんファインプレー!早く！
はじめ: エイちゃん！
エイジ: うああああああああ
はじめ: いだッ！
《ブシャァ》
《ドサァ》
エイジ: 大丈夫ですか？
はじめ: ちょっと待って…
エイジ: うわあああああああああああああああああ！！
エイジ: うわああああ！うああああ！
《走って逃げる音》
《ドアが閉まる音》
リクヲ: え？
リクヲ: (笑)
リクヲ: 風船...w
はじめ: ねぇ、風船だったからバレちゃったやん笑
エイジ: え？どうしたんですか？
はじめ: りっくんが近寄って来て
はじめ: 『あっ、風船・・・ｗ』
はじめ: って終わった笑
はじめ・エイジ・リクヲ: （笑い声）